white privilege so let me get this
straight so that means somebody has
privileges over me because they're white
really you really believe that I don't
buy that that's somebody that messaged
me on Facebook a couple of days ago
saying you know cuz I posted the fact
that I was in the military as somebody
being Middle Eastern and this person
said you know I really feel bad I have
to really you know understand what it
must feel like as a Middle Eastern man
to be in the Army and be judged and
discriminated and yeah I dunno I
understand how white privileges but I'm
getting the better feeling about it
lately better have some privileges you
don't have who made you this decide that
you have privileges that I don't have
who are you to even say that like
seriously let me get this straight I
came from a broken family parents got a
divorce mom ran out of money went back
to Iran I joined the army okay yes I
didn't have a you know the fanciest life
we never lived in a house I don't know
what it is to have money but I decided
to create privileges for myself I like
good food so I want to work hard I
create a privileges for myself I got in
an industry of financial services day
before 9/11 as a middle-eastern man and
9/11 was caused the last time I checked
by folks from the Middle East and that's
when I got into the industry
I didn't say oh my gosh let me not go
sell stocks and money under management
and insurance and annuities because I'm
Middle Eastern no you don't have
privileges over me because you're white
you don't you don't have privileges over
me because you're Middle Eastern matter
of fact on the census it says white
African American Native American Pacific
Islander Asian there is nothing in there
that says Middle Eastern and I still
don't think you have privilege over me I
don't want my kids to grow up thinking
oh they're a Syrian Armenian they're not
privileged because they're a Syrian
Armenian no no they're privileged
because they're Abed David living in
America that's the greatest privilege
you have you live in an America what
other kind of privilege do you want so
look again
some people are not gonna like what I'm
saying right now
but I'll give you the shout apart if you
really believe and allow other people to
make you believe that they have a
privilege over you you're undermining
your own talents and you're undermining
if you believe in a man upstairs god
you're undermining the man that created
you or the parents that raised you I'm
not gonna do that you don't have any
privileges over me if I outwork you if I
read more books than you if I improve
myself if I get the right strategies if
I'm able to last a long time because I
have stamina and I don't fatigue early I
get to win that is my privilege even
though this guy looks like this with a
nose that's pointy how many big noses
you see like this and ears like this I
am privileged you're not privileged so
no don't feel bad for this privileged
guy I choose my privileges not my skin
color my work ethic does my desire to
learn does my desire to come up with
better strategies and constantly last a
long time that's how my privilege came
my way not because my skin color so
again no I don't believe in white
privileges